pour Loïc fabriquer une bonne bière de
Noël n'a plus de secrets il faut d'abord
bien choisir son malt alors là je
récupère du mal de choco donc le malt au
chocolat c'est un malt qu'on va avoir en
petite quantité dans notre bière de Noël
mais qui va nous permettre d'avoir des
reflets rougesâtres c'est celui à partir
du mois de novembre quand on aime bien
voir parce que on se dit que c'est le
high nous réchauffe un peu le cœur avec
le temps qu'il y a dehors
presque pas tout à fait quoi que le
matin quand je brasse la mère de Noël ça
sent le petit déjeuner donc finalement
c'est ses pavettes ce Malte torréfié
passe ensuite par les différentes étapes
de fabrication de la bière le concassage
le brassage la fermentation jusqu'à la
phase d'ébullition pour filtrer le futur
breuvage et lui attribuer son identité
gustative
cette étape là aussi d'ébullition va
nous permettre d'ajouter les houblons
pour l'amertume en début d'ébullition et
aussi savoir sur quel arôme quelle
saveur vont se dégager de cette bière
par exemple dans la bière de Noël voilà
on va vouloir retrouver des côtés un peu
orange pain d'épices donc un peu les
saveurs on va dire de ce qu'on mange à
Noël et donc c'est ça qu'on va qu'on va
rajouter en fait en fin d'ébullition
pour avoir notre recette de la bière de
Noël le résultat repose donc sécu dont
la commercialisation a commencé il y a
déjà un mois en tout cette brasserie
artisanale située près de Chartres a
produit 16000 litres de ber de Noël pour
les fêtes une production débutée dès le
mois d'août
qu'il faut vraiment anticiper les choses
parce que finalement le créneau Noël est
très très court
une fois qu'on a passé Noël bière de
Noël ça n'a plus de sens donc du coup on
a vraiment deux mois pour commercialiser
ce produit et donc il faut vraiment faut
vraiment que voilà être très rapide faut
être très présent dans les magasins et
et faire une grosse communication au
moment venu Vincent Crosnier a fondé la
brasserie sur la ferme familiale en 2005
après les classiques blanches blondes et
brunes il décide de lancer sa propre
bière de Noël un an plus tard une
recette qu'il a adapté au goût du jour
car l'histoire de ce breuvage remonte au
XVIIIe siècle
donc souvent c'était une bière qui était
brassée pour pour la fin d'année en
termes de de d'offrande de récompense
par les par les salariés d'une brasserie
où ils avaient la possibilité d'utiliser
un petit peu tous les restes de ce qui
de ce qui pouvait traîner en terme
d'ingrédients dans la brasserie et
concevoir un petit peu une recette
unique avant de avant d'attaquer l'hiver
depuis elle est devenue un produit
incontournable en fin d'année chaque
brasserie artisanale sort sa propre
recette très ronde
qui a quand même une belle saveur
un petit peu plus charnue parce qu'on
est quand même sur une bien raciste un
petit peu de caractère gentiment mais
c'est quand même très rond en bouche une
bière généreuse à consommer avec des
noix de Saint-Jacques toutes sortes de
plats en sauce mais aussi avec
modération bien entendu